this week on the boys
let them fight
in response to the devastating terrorist
attack in new york city a few days ago
the deep has rallied some of his
celebrity friends to sing john lennon's
imagine now where have i seen this
before these past few days
got me feeling a bit philosophical uh
past few days have got me feeling a
little um
well philosophical yes way back at the
start of the coveted lockdowns wonder
woman herself sent out this absolutely
cringe-inducing video but the deep has
her beat and has included ads for his
new book deeper because everyone at
vaught knows you gotta capitalize on a
tragedy
being attractive
is its own sort of prison
[Music]
deep's rendition includes cameos from
patton oswalt who voiced the deep's
gills in season 2 a train josh gad
ashton kutcher and mila kunis elizabeth
banks kumail nanjani who voiced vic in
the boys diabolical aisha tyler who
voiced nubia rose byrne who starred
alongside seth rogen and neighbors and
my personal favorite black noir also
love having the greek god of the sea
poseidon behind him here back at vots
crime analytics where the deep fire
pretty much the entire staff for having
anti-vot comments on their social media
homelander and the team investigate the
attack on crimson countess for those of
you who haven't seen it there's an
amazing chimp stone crime music video on
the vaught youtube channel which i'll
leave a link to in the description but
the shocking thing here and no it's not
ashley's dick van dyke outfit from mary
poppins but the realization that soldier
boy is back it just goes to show you how
secretive this cover-up was when both
the current ceo avant and the most
powerful soup in the world didn't even
know the truth about his disappearance
regardless homelander knows if this gets
out it's bad news for him and vaught so
he tasks the deep with burying the
footage i'm sure nothing will go wrong
what if we stopped offering thoughts and
prayers and instead
offered prayers and thoughts
[Music]
homelander doesn't seem to be taking the
stress of leading this company too well
and he'll experience this ringing
similar to what he experienced last
episode and the first person he trusts
with this new info that soldier boy is
back is black noir who actually served a
long soldier boy in the group payback
back in the 80s black noir knows the
truth about what happened to soldier boy
and immediately rips out the vaught
tracking chip in his arm he knows that
soldier boy will be after him but just
where he's off to no one really knows in
the season 3 trailer we do see him
eating some delicious vaught beans at a
buster beavers but we're not exactly
sure why he's there soldier boys
delivered an order of vadaburger there
was even a twitter campaign a few months
ago where you could get a real
vodaburger delivered to your home
from vlog you know what i just ain't
there's also a dawn of the seven
collectors cup now soldier boy's demands
aren't too crazy just a giant thing of
booze and some benzoids and that's one
of the funniest things about soldier
boy's character he doesn't know
everything that's changed in that time
his references are terribly outdated
like emmanuel lewis who played webster
or even bill cosby holy [__] did he make
some strong drinks it's this
unfamiliarity with the new world that
eventually convinces soldier boy he'll
need butcher and huey's help in tracking
down the other members of payback if
they help him exact revenge then soldier
boy will help them with their homelander
problem now there are some cool things
to note here one is this weird goo huey
finds in his ear it's about a 3 second
shot and then it's never really brought
up again i'm stumped on what it is but
they wouldn't have put this shot here
unless it'll play some significance is
it a side effect left over from him
taking temp v something that got lodged
in there from the bombing last episode
exposure to radiation what do you guys
think huey also attempts to pick up
soldier boy's shield which is way too
damn heavy just showing how strong this
shield and soldier boy is enjoying a
delicious brave maeve rainbow pop kimiko
debates on how to text frenchie after
their somewhat awkward kiss last episode
he hasn't been around having been
kidnapped by little nina but kimiko
thinks she may have scared him off on
the rainbow pop we get a setup for a
joke why did the photo go to jail and
it's only when the popsicle stick is
literally punched into this dude's neck
that we get the punch line because he
was framed kimiko watches a family
outside the hospital window perhaps
dreaming of a life she wants for herself
and frenchie unfortunately that dream is
put on hold when she's captured by
nina's thug mother's milk prepares for
war against soldier boy even going so
far as to tell starlight the guns aren't
for soldier boy but implying therefore
butcher it's starlight however that
reminds me that they're all they've got
on the wall we can make out several
pictures from the civil rights era as
well as a poster with the phrase move on
over or we'll move on over you which was
later adopted by the black panther party
for self-defense in oakland california
mm is a lot like these civil rights
leaders fighting against an injustice an
enemy that seems unbeatable later in the
episode we'll find out what really
happened to him and his grandfather
we've seen a few flashbacks of these in
episodes four and five soldier boy threw
a car into the apartment mother's milk
and his grandfather lived in but it was
mm who awoke his grandfather telling him
that soldier boy was there and if it
weren't for him waking him up his
grandfather would never have been hit by
that car so mother's milk feels
responsible for his grandfather's death
and lives with this feeling that soldier
boy will come back and kill the rest of
his family the only way he thinks he can
get rid of this feeling is by killing
soulja boy however there is an
alternative his wife hinted at and
that's to move on mother's milk knows
that soldier boy will be hunting down
the rest of payback saying that crimson
countess wasn't smart enough to bring
soldier boy down on his own from this
photo here we can see which members of
payback remain from left we have suado
who was killed in nicaragua black noir
who's on the run crimson countess
deceased gunpowder killed by butcher the
tnt twins who have retired and now
reside in vermont and mindstorm if
mindstorm is still alive expect him to
be next on soldier boy's kill list there
is a shot in the trailer of soldier boy
going absolutely to town smashing his
shield into someone's face could this be
mine storm maybe it's a flashback or it
could be someone else whoever it is it's
someone who really enrages soldier boy
in a room still filled with
congratulations flowers for her
promotion actually watches the newest
promo for a trains a train to africa but
a train really wants to know what vots
doing to reprimand bluehawk for his
violent attack at the black community
center which left his brother nathan
unable to walk like homelander ashley is
under tremendous stress which manifests
in the loss of her hair this has been a
common thread for the past two seasons
can you believe ryan has never seen
candy i'm in your hair
oh nothing and when a train finds out
blue hawk is only getting 12 weeks of
sensitivity training for what he did he
demands justice but it's ashley who mans
up and asks where was the justice when a
train killed innocents like huey's ex
robin or how he injected popclaw with
multiple heroin needles to kill her in
season 1. he seems to want justice only
when it matters to him the deep tells
homelander that black noir cut out his
tracking chip essentially telegraphing
to homelander that black noir was
somehow involved in soldier boy's
disappearance the two used to be
teammates you'd think black noir would
be happy to see his friend back but as
crimson countess stated i hated you
we all did with a little push from
cassandra who's always pulling the deep
strings the deep tells homelanders
soldier boy will likely be after the
other members of payback so the deep is
sent to the tnt twins home in vermont
and tasks to call for homelanders should
soldier boys show up homelanders
apartment is surrounded by historical us
figures these were put here by vaught as
the identity vot wanted him to have as
actor anthony starr tells vanity fair
everything in that apartment is just a
generic piece of americana something
reflective of who they
believe that homelanders should be
speaking of homelanders identity we have
him talking to an alter ego remember
that homelander was essentially raised
in a lab so as a protective mechanism
this alpha homelander alter ego was
created we've never had such an in-depth
look into his character before where
homelander flat out says what he wants
more than anything else want them to
love me a love he never got as a child
and somewhat explains his obsession with
mothers and breast milk it's this desire
to be loved that alpha homelander wants
to cut out of him that last trace of
humanity so he can finally be pure and
clean this old soldier boy movie where
he fights alongside tnt and the
mujahideen in afghanistan is pure gold
solid gold hilarious considering the
rebel fighters in afghanistan which the
u.s finance would later go on to form
the taliban who would go on to
mastermind 911. bonus points if you
caught the wilhelm screams
as soldier boy struggles with getting up
to speed with world events he talks
about how he fought for his country on
the beaches of normandy but now it seems
like everyone has moved on and forgotten
about him hughie inquires about that
building he blew up in new york but
honestly soldier boyd has no
recollection of it telling huey that he
blacked out for 10 minutes and doesn't
remember what happened we'll later see
how certain things trigger soldier boy
which might hint at his weakness with
the location of tnt found by butcher he
and huey shoot up some temp v and get
ready to meet the twins speaking of
which these washed-up has-beens tommy
and tessa welcome in the deep and just
happen to be celebrating hirogasm
basically a giant soup orgy which
coincidentally was founded by soldier
boy and liberty back in 1952. me and
this other soup liberty man was she a
firecracker remember that liberty is
stormfront and it's kind of hinted here
that soldier boy and stormfront banged
there was a theory spreading around last
season that stormfront was homelander's
mother but this new information about
soldier boy could mean that soldier boy
is homelander's father if this somehow
doesn't work out i want to hear your
thoughts in the comments below after a
failed vnn today segment where
homelander once again goes off the rails
congresswoman victoria newman asked to
speak privately with starlight thank god
they're drinking lacroix or is it
lacroix if it were a fresca i would be
concerned victoria comes clean about her
being the head popping soup and even
offers a deal which could be mutually
beneficial for both in exchange for
starlight's impressive clout of 193
million instagram followers something
that could be used to boost victoria's
political career victoria promises to
protect starlight from homelander she is
the head of the federal bureau of
superhero affairs after all but
starlight wants none of it although this
wasn't the outcome victoria wanted it's
a bit scary for starlight as she leaves
the convo with a bloody nose a subtle
reminder that victoria could pop her
head at any moment as punishment for not
killing that father and daughter last
episode a tortured frenchie must choose
between saving kimiko or sherry we're
even given more of frenchie's backstory
an abusive father violent upbringing and
life where he was nothing but someone's
lap dog nina can recite almost every
scar on frenchie's body showing just how
far back these two go and just when it
looks like both kimiko and sherry will
be killed kimiko breaks free and
absolutely slaughters the enemies but
the question i have is are kimiko's
powers slowly coming back we saw at the
end of episode 4 kimiko lose her powers
as a result of soldier boy's blast we
don't know why this happened or if these
changes are permanent now the two
biggest arguments in favor of her powers
coming back one she had the strength to
break this dude's wrist and two she
survives this absolutely brutal beating
we do see her getting bandaged up by
frenchie later in the episode so if she
is getting her powers back this is
likely very gradual or it could be that
she has them back but just in a weakened
state to be determined near the end of
the episode kimiko talks about how it
wasn't the v that made her a monster she
was always a monster contradicting what
she said in episode 2 about how the
shining light liberation army made her
that way kimiko and frenchie admit they
can't escape their past lives i suppose
no one can run that vest so maybe
running off to live in marsai isn't in
the cards maybe they need to confront
their past head-on which would mean
frenchie taking on little nina she did
after all disappear during the fight
starlight and mother's milk arrive at
herogasm greeted by love sausage who mm
knows quite intimately from last season
while attending sage grove center i
really don't know how i'm going to edit
this next part of the video i haven't
dodged this many dicks since it was
senior's day at the community pool
change room there's a flying starlight
dildo the same model found in the
russian dudes collection now is it just
me or are the outfits for the catering
staff the same as those from party down
if you haven't seen that show it's a
must-watch every episode they cater like
a really weird party termite is here
seemingly learning nothing from his
altercation in episode 1 but starlight
and mm are professionals and need to get
these people out of here before soldier
boy comes see what i did there starlight
tries to get bluehawk to leave telling
him that soldier boy is back but he
thinks that's just another lie
perpetuated by the lame stream media
something tells me him participating in
hirogasm isn't part of his sensitivity
training starlight finds the deep balls
deep in some puss an octopus that is
he's had a thing for these suckers since
making love to cassandra a few episodes
ago focusing more on the one in his
aquarium than her starlight does take a
compromising photo of him here not sure
if this will be used as blackmail going
forward hughie teleports into the party
making him appropriately dressed with
him hopped up on compound v he finally
has the courage to demand an apology
from a train for killing his girlfriend
way back in season one and to his
surprise a train does apologize because
he knows what it's like to see someone
you love get hurt hughie punches atrain
and atran can't believe how he did it
this was something i found a bit
confusing was it because huey was on
temp v and actually hurt a-train with
his strength or that huey punched so
fast that a-train's superhuman reflexes
weren't fast enough to dodge the punch
with soldier boy arriving on scene and
[__] about to go down huey teleports
starlight away for once he wants to be
the one to save her i saved you annie
jesus christ all i want is to save you
what we find out is that huey's been
struggling with some toxic masculinity
bothered by the fact he can't be a man
and save his girl even though he told
starlight this wouldn't affect him it's
the moment mother's milk has been
waiting for a chance to take on soulja
boy but the halothane canister he
thought would knock him out has no
effect we saw soulja boy get knocked out
by some sort of gas by the russians but
it's never explained why this halothane
doesn't do it is it the wrong kind of
gas or has soldier boy gotten stronger
now soldier boy could have easily killed
mm here if it weren't for butcher in
fact butcher saves mm's life here by not
allowing him to go after soldier boy the
tnt twins are finally confronted by
soldier boy and they say the plan to
take him down was all black noirs and
soulja boy knows who i wouldn't take a
[__]
without vats say so if soldier boy was
fooling around with stormfront this
would also give frederick vaught
stormfront's husband a personal reason
to get rid of him stan edgar at the time
wasn't the head of the company so
someone higher up than him probably made
that decision now i also subscribe to
the theory that stan edgar is frederick
vaught i've talked about this more in my
season 2 ending explain video but if
that's true this whole soulja boy
homelander storefront love triangle gets
a heck of a lot messier love sausage's
russian boner jams trigger soldier boy
just like the radio a few episodes ago
triggered him in new york the tnt twins
try their powers which they say they
haven't used in years but much like
their careers it's fizzled out now
soldier boy's attack causes absolute
devastation with several people dying
and the consequences of which we're just
not quite sure yet like did any of the
supes lose their powers like kimiko
after this blast now if huey and
starlight's relationship couldn't get
any worse he basically demands starlight
not go back and she's like
the deep saves his octopus friend loves
sausage's sausage is burnt like one and
a train takes the opportunity to take
blue hawk for a little run now a train
has been warned that using his ability
could cause him to have a massive heart
attack which is exactly what happens
we're kind of left with this is he or
isn't he dead seen and honestly it could
go either way termite gets crushed by
homelander and butcher checks to see if
mother's milk is okay starlight will
later take mm to safety pleading to him
not to fight reciting the words she said
to him earlier that it's up to them to
help the people just like last time
soldier boy has no recollection of this
attack but soon they're interrupted by
homelander and it's here we find out
soldier boy was homelander's hero
growing up what follows is one of my
favorite fight scenes on the boys ever
the world's two strongest soups battle
it out and after a bit i have to say
homelander has a bit of an edge over
soldier boy here eventually gaining the
upper hand but it's the addition of
butcher and later huey with their temp v
that proves homelander can be defeated i
love how soldier boy uses homelanders
cape something he criticized as not
being manly against him in the fight the
three of them combined are able to pin
homelander down with soldier boy
charging up his power and butcher yells
at huey to leave proving again that he
is looking out for him like a brother
but homelander is too strong and manages
to escape after this fight we'll see
homelander looking at himself in the
mirror with a clearly visible bruise
we've never seen homelander even
remotely injured before even the legend
says he's never seen homelander break so
much as a sweat so if i were homelander
now i'd be extremely scared during the
aftermath there are these two quick back
and forth one between butcher and mmm
and one between starlight and huey
neither of these relationships have
healed at all in fact the rift between
them has only grown further apart after
this altercation with soldier boy
looking at the dead soups in front of
her starlight knows she has to do
something drastic going live to her
millions of followers and telling them
the truth that soldier boy was the one
who caused this vote's been lying to
them and that all vot and the supes care
about is their image she even discloses
that homelander did something to maeve
we still don't know where she is there's
a lot of support for starlight in the
chat with lots of people using the
hashtag vaut lied people died starlight
ends up quitting vaut and the seven
making this the fourth episode in a row
that ends on her character we know that
vot is amazing at covering things up and
spinning stories they have their own
news network after all in the season 3
trailer we see yet to be seen footage of
homelander being greeted by adoring fans
with a toppled statue of soldier boy so
if i were to hazard a guess homelander
is going to turn soulja boy and the boys
into wanted fugitives in attendance are
storm chasers the super far-right fans
of stormfront as well as
pro-trump-inspired fans who wear sorry
snowflake t-shirts and one dude who
looks like that freedom viking who is
sent to jail for the january 6
insurrection so it looks like homelander
is going to cultivate this group while
starlight america's sweetheart takes on
more of the mainstream that is of course
unless vaught has some bad dirt on her
and publicly smears her whatever the
case may be i wouldn't be surprised if
ashley is bald by the end of the season
thanks for watching everyone be sure to
like and subscribe i'll be covering
every episode of the season and for more
bad takes you can follow me on twitter
and instagram at thingstoryt until next
time remember he just gobbles that
vagina right up
you